einem forschungsteam aus japan ist etwas
unglaubliches gelungenes hat die
superkräfte in der bärtierchen in
menschliche zellen eingeschleust sie
überleben nämlich jede katastrophe egal
ob radioaktiver unfall gigantische
chemie katastrophe oder die komplette
austrocknung der erde
wie das genau funktioniert und ob wir
jetzt alle superhelden werden ein video
in zusammenarbeit mit der mega polen
zeitschrift technology review
am ende des videos gibt's ein gratis
exemplar für euch als geschenk klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
optisch gesehen sind bärtierchen alles
andere als außergewöhnlich sie sind
verwandt mit dem gliedertieren also
beispielsweise den spinnenmann findet
sie zwischen alten blättern und moos und
um sie zu entdecken brauchen wir eine
lupe sie sind etwa einen millimeter lang
haben einen rundlichen körper und acht
beinchen doch forschungsteams weltweit
sind mehr als angetan von diesem kleinen
kirchen denn sie sind wahre
überlebenskünstler weder lange
trockenheit noch radioaktivität können
ihnen etwas an namen setzen eine chemie
katastrophe unsere umwelt zerstören
würde wären die bärtierchen wohl immer
noch am start und das wohl bei bester
gesundheit doch wie kann das sein wie
sind diese lebewesen in der lage quasi
wieder aufzuerstehen nachdem ihr
kompletter lebensraum monatelang
ausgetrocknet war fest steht die dna
tierischer zellen ist dafür nicht
ausgelegt bleiben wir beim beispiel des
wasser entzuges die molekülketten
brechen bei derart lebensfeindlichen
bedingungen auseinander auch bei
radioaktiver strahlung die in den
zellkern gelangen sieht es schlecht aus
für das erbgut doch bärtierchen
überleben strahlendosen achtung bis zu
1000 dre das ist absoluter wahnsinn wenn
man sich mal überlegt dass helfer nach
der reaktorkatastrophe von tschernobyl
bei strahlendosen von 2 bis 20 grad
starb erst 2017 war ein forschungsteam
aus japan dem geheimnis der bärtigen auf
die schliche gekommen
eine schutzhülle rund um das erbgut der
lebewesen fängt alle schädlichen
einflüsse ab dazu einer der beteiligten
forscher von der universität tokio
takeda zu boney m sie können einfach so
zwischen leben und beinahe toten hin und
her wechseln da
unglaublich konkret handelt es sich um
ein protein das das erbgut vor schäden
bewahrt in der fachsprache genannt
vorstellen kann man sich das tatsächlich
wäre eine art superhelden kate an der
dna befestigt ist es durch elektrische
anziehung aber das eben nur an der einen
seite an der anderen seite flattert es
locker herum und sorgt so für den schutz
das hatten die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler bei den strahlungs
tolerantesten aller bisher bekannten
bärtierchen dem sogenannten ramazzottis
vario natus herausfinden können und das
forschungsteam ging noch weiter
das ziel war es diese superkräfte auch
auf menschliche zellen zu übertragen
gesagt getan auch hier wurde das erbgut
mit dem entsprechenden protein
ausgestattet ja und haltet euch fest die
so manipulierten seelenleben trotz einer
tödlichen bestrahlung von vier gray
nicht nur weiter sondern teilten sich
sogar weiterhin ein wirklich
vielversprechend das ergebnis was
allerdings so nicht so 100 prozent auf
den menschen übertragbar ist denn die
für das experiment genutzten zellen
wurden so verändert dass sie eher
krebszellen ähnlich sind und nicht
normalen körperzellen
doch der japanische forscher nun jeder
ist dennoch optimistisch wenn wir
verstehen was bärtierchen so stark macht
dann können wir diese stärken später
einmal auf weniger starke spezies
übertragen menschen eingeschlossen war
vielen dank an die redaktion von
technology review für das ama thema und
noch weitere unglaubliche themen gibt es
in dem gratis heft dass ihr bekommt wenn
er darauf klickt also klicken und
staunen wenn ich mal sagen und hier
darunter geht es weiter mit einem
anderen coolen thema von technology
review dafür auch draufklicken
mysteriöse grauzone zwischen leben und
tod wachkomapatienten bei bewusstsein
bis dahin bleibt dran